bonjour mona alors c'est donc
aujourd'hui que les associations et
lusine lubrizol connaîtront la décision
du juge est exactement c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils seront fixés sur leur sort le
brizault conteste sa mise en examen
l'usiné face à deux chefs d'inculpation
le premier est déversement de substances
musique dans les eaux naturelles et
exploitation non conforme et y apporter
emporté graves atteintes à la santé la
sécurité ou l'environnement la multi el
nacional est dénoncé des irrégularités
dans les procédures estime ne pas avoir
eu un procès équitable
lusine avait déposé une requête en
nullité le 30 partenaires une procédure
qui permet à lequel de la procédure ici
en l'occurrence c'est elle la mise en
alors monaci la justice annule la mise
en examen il n'y aura pas de procès
comment le vivent les victimes
vous en doutez ils le vivent très mal
notamment l'association de l'est de
l'union des victimes de lubrizol prend
cette contestation comme je cite un
doigt d'honneur ils sont très en colère
selon christoph hohl ville je le cite il
ya une complaisance de la part de l'état
vis-à-vis et des industriels souvenez
vous cette avant cette affaire qui
compte dorénavant plus de 500 plaintes
de riverains le 26 septembre 2019 un
important incendie s'était a déclaré
s'était propagé un immense nuage de
fumée avec plus de 100 mille tonnes de
produits chimiques lâchés dans la nature
il y a deux ans nous étions allés sur
place et nous avions rencontré ces
riverains et qui nous expliquait bien
qu'ils souffraient de maux de tête de
nausées et autres questions que se
posent les riverains comptent ils
respirent et les victimes ont dû faire
eux-mêmes et des prélèvements et des
analyses pour tenter de le savoir avec
peut-être des conséquences pour la santé
c'est en tout cas ce qui nous expliquait
vous l'avez donc compris et les victimes
attendent beaucoup de ce délibéré
aujourd'hui espère voir se tenir un
procès merci beaucoup mona pour ces
précisions - namouh dès lors en direct
devant la cour d'appel de paris